how excited are you for the reuniting a
friend Lisa Kudrow Anthony Anderson and
other iconic funny men and women united
for the Paley Center comedy legends
event where we asked if we'll ever get a
reboot of this legendary sitcom what I
consider yeah but I'm not the Lynch just
happened we might be the only show where
we're a little less charming in our 50s
and 60s than we were in our 30s and 40s
you don't want us growing up so it might
be a little pathetic for us to be stuck
where we were 30 years ago Carol Burnett
and Bob Newhart had a red carpet running
could they return to some of their
funniest cameo roles Mad About You is
back and you are Helens mom yep I'm
gonna go back and do that again oh I
can't wait to see them any chance we're
gonna see you in Legally Blonde three
since you were in Legally Blonde - this
is perfect this is exactly what I need
we're talking okay you're talking with
recess reason now I tell everybody I'm
talking Lincoln and while Dolly Parton
has doubts about her highly anticipated
sequel
I think we've dropped that whole idea
Lilly's not giving up hope of course I
want to team up absolutely and whether
it would be 9:00 to 5:00 or something
else but I haven't given up
[Music]